average each patient that we're treating
in this intensive care unit is costing
500 pounds so many children have died
unnecessarily because we doctors don't
have the drugs
and the equipment needed to save them
with your donation you will enable us to
be able to save lives by the permission
of allah
this app has been such a game changer to
me i've never been so consistent with my
quran reading before i knew about quran
lee you can get quran li absolutely free
no credit card for seven day free trial
what are you waiting for download it now
brown sisters and build a habit with the
qurani app right now just to reiterate
so my question was if we lived in an
island yes and there was all vegans yes
and i was a vegan yes and one day i
happened to
eat something which was me and i went
this is bloody amazing yes and where did
this come from and i realized i don't
know
somebody was cooking and he said to me
listen i'm staying away from this vegan
yes yes i live in the uh jungle and i
eat meat join me i'm not bloody of
course i'm bloody joining this is bloody
amazing they've been telling me okay so
now the point would be that that would
be an excitement to violence saying
let's not be vegan would be
let's kill these animals
if i started coming out to your
gatherings yes and i said guys try this
meat and tell me if it's bad yes would
you stop me
uh
so without getting too technical this is
meat that's been that an animal has been
killed for it's not like roadkill or
something like that i had no meat i just
said i want to preach that people should
eat meat
i think so i'm a bit of a free speech
absolutist i know i guess things that we
should so we should go and kill these
animals okay i i would i would say that
that is not defensible free speech
that's a direct incitement to violence
okay so again not as bad it's it's on
the same track so they're saying like
let's go and kill these people's over
here let's go and kill these animals
over here it's still wrong but it's
nowhere not as bad okay so therefore if
i made an argument intellectually and i
said these are the top five reasons we
should eat meat yes okay for example if
i realized that
we're stronger arguments okay we can do
more we can produce more it's going to
be better for our greater community
argumentation well none of that stuff is
true
necessarily yes but let's say so would
you allow me to preach to the masses and
when you start seeing your vegan friends
coming and saying
i have a point
would there be a concern in your mind of
i need to stop this guy
because otherwise it's going to make us
all meat eaters it would be a concern in
a similar way that if you had someone
who was convincing people to go and kill
people who were saying let's go i don't
believe that's the same thing it's not
the same it's not as bad don't get me
wrong but it's in a like this would be a
worse point if someone was saying right
let's go out and kill people
and making arguments to go and kill
people i'd say that speech isn't
protected and that you should be
sanctioned for that i don't think they
should be killed for that what would you
do with me what would you what would you
do with me uh
i would give you i think the first thing
i would do would be to give you a fine
you know again i'm not i'm not sure
about the legal punishment i know it's
morally wrong no no you guys are running
you guys in the ruling
go as much as i want everyone to be
vegan i'm not qualified to be a dictator
what would you do you need to understand
so
so let's say that so it's an assembly if
someone was going out now and saying
let's kill people which again i think is
worse than saying let's kill animals
yeah but that's but it's in about the
same squad saying let's kill people i
don't think we should kill that person
nobody i think we should no problem
in your eyes killing an animal is
killing a human being no problem
again not in the
you have someone indirectly promoting
something which is severe to you he's
seen as an animal you're seeing it is
yes close to killing a human yes what
would you do to stop his propaganda uh i
wouldn't kill them
i think what you would ultimately you'd
give him an incentive not to essentially
punish him like a fine or something like
we would do now if someone was saying
that whip him publicly
okay no problem
because another thing about punishment
as well because i don't believe in free
will i don't think like you you punish
for a deterrent sake you don't punish
because they're a bad person okay no
problem
just say with this one i would take this
person yeah you'd you'd incentivize them
to like a fine or something because if
they carried on you would have to stop
their speech you'd have to lock them up
this would be like we're doing now with
like
preachers now who are saying we should
go around and kill everyone like like
you know i i can't think of an example
now but the people who encourage people
to go and join us
we lock them up because they're giving
us a direct assignment to violence
really and stop their speech from being
heard i don't think we should kill them
brilliant
you agreed with me on something yes that
the fact that i as a mediator will cause
some kind of a corruption in society
which may lead to something which you
deem to be greater than what it actually
is but in your eyes you believe is
closer to killing a human being you will
take measures and precautions to stop me
from that speech
in islam when we look at a apostate yes
we are not saying by the way let me make
it very clear
bounty hunting or uh what do they call
that word when you go and hunt um
apostates there's word for
vigilantism yeah yes it's not allowed in
islam i can't go like what's there whoa
so
as muslims for us somebody leaving their
religion is not the issue here the issue
is the propagation because now you're
according to your way which is not going
to just kill your soul but kill and kill
your body but it's going to destroy the
soul of others i see it and islam has
come to protect there's fighting islam
has come for to protect the mind to
protect the wealth to protect their
health to protect the lineage and
protect the religion of uh people so
when you are having an outright attack
and all of these things have major
capital punishments when somebody is
coming and saying things
which is
against islam abusing islam as as a
muslim we have a right to protect our
community as a whole just to where you
protect your community of veganism
so we say that this person doesn't want
to be a muslim
bye leave the country look the world is
vast see you later if you're gonna come
and say no i'm gonna carry on preaching
islam has a capital punishment i see and
that to me is justified how this is not
exclusive to muslims as a vegan i asked
you a question you said yes i will not
give you the capital punishment i will
put you in prison i'll be honest rotting
in prison for the rest of my life i
think i prefer death so the point is
this because
the question is that islam is not a
blood thirsty religion islam wants order
and to protect the communal rights as a
whole an individual cannot come and say
i want to drink alcohol that alcohol
might cause you to drink drive and kill
five people yes you are not allowed to
drink alcohol because your right is
going to transgress the right of others
so what islam says is that we are here
to protect our religion if you have left
it
there's the door if you want to cause
corruption here's the capital punishment
so what would happen then i'm trying to
think now of some of the guys on youtube
uh
so i guess iron hersey would be there
i don't know if she was ever a muslim
and her story she got kicked out of
netherlands because of a fake
story of how she was abused
i don't know if you saw it there was a
documentary done yeah she got she lost
herself so would she but if she
proclaims to be an apostate he
criticizes islam she would be killed
under the syrian society look there is a
capital punishment but there's also for
example ibrahim had a view which he used
evidence from the treaty of odaibia
there was a treaty
that was done that
for example if we have the deportation
yes yes it's like exile but but if but
in the world that you want to live in
i want to live in a vegan world you want
to in this world so
there's no there's there's nowhere to be
deported what would happen to like alien
hersey
i think this republic apostate
these guys he doesn't even know how to
recite the shortest verse in the quran
we have a question
capital punishment will be applied to
all of these uh
vocals and we are proud of that
you know why just as the way as a vegan
you would protect
your community as a whole we as muslims
are not asking for anything i guess for
me it's not about protecting vegans
because i don't think they're vegans and
also we've got that just so excited
sure we looked at some ottoman
statistics mohammed looked at the
ottoman empire which ruled for a
significant amount
do you know there was hardly capital
punishment applied in the prostates
there was imprisonment they looked at
data so this is the question is it's
also is the decision of the ruler if the
ruler says
you know what just look him up
let me locked up but what i'm saying is
what islam promotes
is not something exclusive to us
all groups of people being veganism
judaism christianity islam every human
being has these regulations in place to
protect it for example edward snowden
whatever that was supposed to do in
russia
wikileaks
the question what i'm saying is they all
apply it in different ways but john i
have to follow thank you very much it's
been a pleasure it really was i really
enjoyed
a youtube channel yes my name is
thank you very much it was a pleasure
talking to you and i hope you guys
enjoyed that discussion guys
[Music]